this week on brian ross investigates the
money duck christian broadcaster william
neil gallagher promised his followers
huge financial rewards if they invested
with him
less government
more personal responsibility
with the help of god a better world
but prosecutors say this man of god was
a crook we found that there was a very
very large ponzi scheme
that was going on
almost 200 victims cheated out of some
28 million dollars fraudulent transfers
were made to his mistress so this man of
god had a mistress
he indeed had at least one plus the man
who tried to blow the whistle on bernie
madoff and his ponzi scheme
harry marco polo says the schemes
continue to this day they come across
them seemingly every month and they're
everywhere in every community
his advice on how to spot them anytime
you see the word guarantee run don't
walk away from the investment it's a
scam and this week's winners and losers
in the media as chosen by the editors of
mediaite
see if you agree with what they had to
say about this white house correspondent
but he was utterly delusional
especially in talking about the events
of january
from the law and crime trial network
this is dragon rost investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague here at law and
crime rhonda schwartz and rhonda we
begin with a story of a massive fraud
scheme that targeted followers of a
popular christian radio broadcaster who
it turns out was running a massive ponzi
scheme rhonda
that's right brian it was more than a
hundred years ago that an italian
immigrant named charles ponzi became
infamous his name forever linked to
financial crime after bilking his
investors of some 20 million dollars
which would be close to a quarter
billion in today's dollars brian and
ronna since then ponzi schemes have
again and again been used to cheat
unsuspecting investors including most
recently by bernie madoff and now this
new case that unfolded in texas
dr neil gallagher is a premier true
american
with integrity in all his pursuits
his key goal is to help others take
responsibility for their financial
future
his life's passion is to help people
retire safe early and happy
he called himself the money doc and his
broadcasts on christian radio and
television outlets gave him a very
receptive audience freedom requires
education and empowerment and i educate
and empower clients
less government
more personal responsibility
and with the help of god a better world
but behind the man of god authorities
say was a duplicitous con man running a
multi-million dollar ponzi scheme
and we're joined now by laurie varnell
who's the chief of the elder fraud unit
in the tarrant county district
attorney's office there in dallas miss
farnell thank you for being with us how
did you get on to this money doc doc
gallagher
well originally the case began by a a
couple that walked into the police
department to complain that
he had taken their money and we opened
an investigation in tarrant county and
started
investigating uh the complaints against
him
and that's when we found that there was
a very very large ponzi scheme
that was going on and help our viewers
understand what is a ponzi scheme
so a ponzi scheme is a scheme in which
you are tricked into investing into
basically somebody's checking account
most of the time
and what happens is
they have
previous investors who are trying to get
their investments have the return uh
it's usually a
it's always up and to the right
so there's no risk whatsoever and it's
always a guaranteed return those are
hallmarks of the sale of a ponzi scheme
so because that's an unreasonable
expectation
they now have to make it pay off for
their earlier investors so they can keep
the scheme going
so they get newer investors and pay
their older investors with new investors
money
all the while they are skimming off the
talk
this is doc gallagher do you know the
number one question to ask a financial
planner how long you've been in business
good question and how long had gallagher
been doing this and how big did it get
to be
so our case uh the indictment started in
2013
but the investors complaints went all
the way back to 2009
and how big it got well he had
almost 200 customers
and he um
according to their claims
uh had taken them for 38 million dollars
and the victims were mostly elderly
yes sir
and these were
their life savings they took their life
savings
gallagher's promotional videos were
shameless
he has authored over 70 professional and
popular articles with four current books
under his belt the money doctor's guide
hunter the four secrets of protecting
your safe money burning passionate
prayers for men on fire and jesus christ
money master in which all of his books
offer a powerful array of financial
understanding and influence
so he was
um
on christian broadcasting networks
and during his time online on those
broadcasting stations he would tell them
see you at church on sunday
and
he would walk in and pray over people
and put his hands on people and they
would tell me they told me about how he
would
act like this was god's will for them
and
um because we live in a community that
has a very large christian
base
uh he had a very wide
listening audience
and was able to amass a great fortune
because of it
and they trusted him because they
thought he was a man of god
yes sir
that's exactly why
and
so um once he walked in the door as a
prayer and a christian
they didn't ask as many questions as
they might have of somebody else
now with over 30 years of his visionary
style dr gallagher has guided over a
thousand individuals in the development
of their financial future with his
company the gallagher financial group
but earlier this year gallagher pleaded
guilty to charges he had built almost
200 of his loyal christian broadcast
listeners showing no signs of remorse in
the courtroom according to the
prosecutor
no none
none whatsoever
he um sat in the courtroom with his arms
crossed and his brow furrowed
and would roll his eyes occasionally and
um really was disrespectful i think to
the victims
and what was his defense
his defense was that he had taken the
money and put it into charity and he was
playing robin hood and that was a huge
lie
he was basically running a ponzi scheme
it was an investment in his checking
account
and what was he doing with the money
so um you know there are a lot of things
that he was doing he was paying ponzi
payments to keep his scheme going
fraudulent transfers were made to his
mistress debbie carter in the amount of
1.6 million dollars
so this man of god had a mistress
he indeed had at least one
not exactly the message the money doc
was preaching to his followers the good
lord has made us to give unconditional
love and to accept unconditional love
you've got to be sure you totally trust
that financial planner you're working
with if i didn't have any money with you
would you still care about me that's the
number one question god bless you what
was the sentence
three life sentences and three ten year
sentences
so he won't be coming out anytime soon
no sir we certainly
don't expect him to be able to
live out that for very long because he's
81 years old so we don't expect him to
get out all right laurie varnell thank
you so much for being with us tonight
very good advice
thank you
the money doc's alleged mistress has
been charged in connection with the
ponzi scheme she has pleaded not guilty
and is scheduled to go on trial sometime
next year coming up next we'll hear from
the certified fraud examiner who tried
to blow the whistle on bernie madoff's
ponzi scheme with advice on what to
watch out for
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law on crime trial network
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galileo gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
the fact is no one knows more about
ponzi schemes than the man who's about
to join us harry marco polos a certified
fraud examiner mr marco polos was the
first person to spot what was going on
with bernie madoff's operation even
though he sent his warnings to the
security exchange commission and they
essentially blew him off
harry later testified about that before
congress as today's testimony will
reveal
my team and i tried our best to get the
sec to investigate and shut down the
madoff ponzi scheme with repeated
incredible warnings to the sec that
started in may 2000
when the man off ponzi scheme was only a
three to seven billion dollar fraud
we knew then that we had provided enough
red flags and mathematical proofs to the
sec for them where they should have been
able to shut him down right then and
there at under seven billion dollars but
by the time birdie madoff's ponzi scheme
collapsed he had cheated his customers
out of more than 64 billion dollars
his massive crime became the subject of
numerous books and two movies including
one on abc featuring richard dreyfuss
based on the book that i wrote about
madoff
you want to know how to get people to
trust you
with their money
you present it as an exclusive thing
right now it's a closed fund
after that you couldn't stop them from
giving you their money if you tried i'm
accusing him of running a ponzi scheme
we got a problem bernie badoff died in
prison earlier this year at the age of
82.
so mr marco polos thank you for being
with us here this evening tell me why
these fraud schemes these ponzi schemes
continue to happen
it's a combination of factors it's
mainly greed you want to believe so
there's hope
you hope that those returns are real you
see other people seemingly getting rich
overnight and get rich quick screams and
they want a piece of the action and so
they fall victim to some very simple
schemes and they spend not one second
actually asking questions can this be
real how can i verify if this is being
real if this is real and so they do zero
due diligence and as a result they get
trapped
and do they rely too much on the
government is the government doing
enough of a job to detect these ponzi
schemes before they accumulate so many
victims
investors can't hope
can't hope that the government's going
to catch these schemes before they get
off the ground a lot of these schemes in
fact all of them start small and then
they get big once a scheme gets big
enough and over a certain size
it will fall onto the government's radar
screen because enough people will become
ensnared and trapped into the scheme
eventually someone's not going to get
paid the fraudsters are going to make
promises and they're going to fail to
deliver and once they do that
these angry investors are going to say
oh i'm going to call the government and
they pick up the phone and they call
either the fbi or the department of
justice sometimes they call the sec
and eventually the government gets onto
the scheme starts investigating and of
course by then it's too late
after the madoff scandal was revealed
and you testified the sec said we're
really going to increase our enforcement
of ponzi schemes have they
yes the sec had 65 recommendations from
the inspector general's office for how
to do a ponzi scheme and do it more
effectively they adopted all 65 measures
recommended
and they're very good at ponzi's games
but they have to first find out about
them and unfortunately they have to get
big enough for someone to make a call
drop a dime and call the government and
tell them about it because they're not
going to proactively have enough people
to investigate every investment offered
to investors there's only 5 000 people
at the sec they're too small to do that
are there currently schemes that you're
looking at which you think are in fact
ponzi schemes
yes i haven't done a ponzi scheme case
in about three years i basically refer
them out right now because i'm busy on
public company accounting fraud cases
but i come across them seemingly every
month and they're everywhere in every
community
what do you see that
tells you this is a ponzi scheme help
our viewers understand what to look for
returns that are guaranteed time you see
the word guarantee run don't walk away
from the investment it's a scam
anything to do with an affinities
program such as religion religion and
money do not mix i think that's in the
bible people should know better and they
seemingly fall for the religious scams
every time
sometimes the schemes have you do
something so you think that you're
working for it in china there were over
a million victims
that thought they could make money by
buying ant farms and farming ants
to make medicine
and that took in a lot of money before
the culprits went to jail in the united
states we saw something equally
ridiculous pigeon farming people were
raising pigeons for the restaurant trade
which you can laugh at it but a lot of
victims in canada and the united states
lost a lot of money thinking they could
make money selling pigeons to
restaurants
you mentioned religious religion and
affinity groups like that this case in
texas involved fundamental christians
what should people think about when
there's an appeal to their religion that
this is somebody i can trust a pastor
i have done religious affiliated ponzi
schemes and they go back
decades a very interesting one was new
era philanthropy in philadelphia ran for
six years from 1989 to 1995
and the culprit john bennett was
promising to double your money if you
would give him 5 000 or more in three
months he would double that and you can
make a charitable donation on your
behalf to a charity of your choosing and
he instead all sorts of endowments
big time endowments and philanthropies
and eventually he was running low on
money so he increased the minimums to
twenty five thousand dollars and
increased the length of time before he
would double your money
well finally it got big enough and it
was a whistleblower who was an
accounting professor at spring arbor
university in michigan
by the name of albert miller
and what he did
he went to the university president and
the university president said
he just gave us a check we doubled our
money and he showed it to him you put it
right in front of his face you were
wrong
this guy this john bennett he's money
well the scheme collapsed and the
university president ended up
apologizing to the accounting professor
but it was too late for the university
they lost the overall it was over a half
a billion dollar scam
has anyone ever apologized to you for
ignoring your warning signs about bernie
madoff
yes i've had several people at the
securities and exchange commission tell
me that they wish they had investigated
more diligently and they they were
embarrassed by the agency's performance
and they vowed to do better and of
course they have they've done a lot
better
and do you think now finally there are
people out there who could one day be as
big of a scammer as bernie madoff was oh
most definitely bernie madoff's record
of 64.8 billion
is going to be broken i hope it's not
going to be broken in the united states
but i do have a feeling it can be broken
and will be broken probably in asia
probably in china probably in russia or
somewhere in eastern europe someplace
where their investors are less
sophisticated than the united states
harry marco bolas thank you so much for
joining us tonight
thank you brian
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media both of them white
house correspondents see if you agree
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who is the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media empire and aiden
this week the winner and the loser both
white house correspondents let's start
with the winner john carl from abc news
whose new book betrayal the last act of
the trump show comes out november 16th
he talked about it on the stephen
colbert show
but he was utterly delusional um and
especially in talking about the events
of january 6 we have a clip here some
people were saying 1776 if it's rigged
if it's being stolen why not
charge i don't know i hadn't heard that
but people were very angry and people
were there that crowd
never the press the fake news which is
fake uh the fake news never talked about
the size of that crowd that crowd was a
massive ground
it was a massive crowd
i mean so he's uh he's missing the
narrative here he's yeah can you imagine
i'm asking about whether he's popular
yeah i'm asking him about a riot i'm
asking about one of the darkest days in
american history and he's talking about
how many people came out to see him
and then mr trump has called it john
carl a third-rate reporter i think that
would be a badge of honor for john a
former colleague of mine
that's right and uh trump also spoke out
about this book which is uh you know you
know you've made it in the uh the
pantheon of trump tell-alls when trump
himself is trashing you in a statement
um but you know i think it's hard to get
excited these days about these trump
expose um particularly ones that focus
on the last months of the trump
administration but this one is just
packed with so much shocking information
about what went on during that insane
time and we've seen a few of bits of
reporting come out in exclusive excerpts
that have been published by various
magazines and uh and websites we know
that john kelly who was trump's chief of
staff for a while wanted the 25th
amendment invoked
during the capital riot and that he
wanted trump effectively deemed unfit
for office and removed we also know that
there are photos of mike pence hiding in
a room during the riot when a bunch of
trump supporters were storming the
capitol and calling for mike pence to be
hanged um those photos were not allowed
to be published by john carl mike
pence's team stopped that from happening
but there's just a lot of really great
reporting here from jonathan carl
who is an outstanding chronicler of the
trump administration
um when he was serving as abc news chief
white house correspondent under that
administration as you say we think we've
heard all about donald trump but every
new book comes out with new details that
just uh you know grab your attention
like you can't believe what's going on
let's talk about this week's loser the
other white house correspondent who you
have dealt with who's a loser tell us
about her
right so emerald robinson she is the
white house correspondent for newsmax
she had been suspended from twitter last
week because she posted a sort of insane
uh conspiracy theory about vaccines that
basically alleged that they had some
sort of tie to satan she was suspended
from twitter she received a rebuke from
newsmax in the form of a statement
she got back on twitter on tuesday
morning and started continuing to push
the conspiracy theory that there's some
sort of satanic tie to these vaccines
within hours she was permanently banned
from twitter so she's no longer on the
platform anymore
and newsmax actually issued another
statement uh this time to the daily
beast saying that she is going to be off
the air at newsmax while the outlet
reviews her social media posts um so not
only was she banned from twitter this
week uh forever uh her job is also in
danger but also of interest this new
newsmax has its own vaccine mandate now
that's true so at mediai we exclusively
reported on friday
that newsmax has started to implement a
vaccine mandate um they're basically
going along with the biden
administration's policy uh where
businesses with more than 100 employees
either have to uh check vaccines or give
testing once a week
so that has created a a lot of
consternation at newsmax because the
network and its hosts have railed
against these vaccine mandates
there's a bit of outcry within the
network we'll see how that plays out
very interesting to see that
essentially a hypocrisy on the part of
the
the company both at newsbacks in some
ways at fox where they have their hosts
uh criticizing the mandates but then
instituting it themselves for their own
employees
that's true and there's always these
little word play that's being going on
where uh newsmax hosts have since said
there is no vaccine mandate at newsmax
because we're not forcing everyone to
get the vaccine because there is the out
uh for weekly testing but of course when
biden unveiled the plan uh that mandated
the vaccines or weekly testing everyone
at newsmax and fox news decried it as a
mandate um so
it's very hypocritical yeah indeed aidan
mclaughlin thank you so much
editor-in-chief of meteorite
and that's our program tonight thanks
for joining us and thanks to our great
crew here at long crime for getting us
on the air and off the air every week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you